the uh tan suit type fake scandals
about joe biden are quickly ramping up
last week we covered tucker carlson's
explosive reporting about how supposedly
joe and jill biden don't really love
each other
their marriage is merely a stage managed
public relations strategy that was last
week
this week we have a clip from newsmax
host
greg kelly saying that joe biden's
choice of
dog isn't very presidential referring of
course to the biden's
senior german shepherd champ and
bringing on a panel to discuss this
important topic
saying biden's dog looks like he's from
a junkyard
check this out did you see the dog let's
get i want to show you something i
noticed
doesn't he look a little a little rough
i love dogs but this dog needs a bath
and a comb
and all kinds of love and care i've
never seen a dog
in the white house uh like this i
remember buddy i remember millie i
remember lots of dogs but not a dog who
seems
i don't know i don't know how much love
and care he is getting let's bring in
the historians
i i'm having fun with this obviously but
i i do want to talk about some stuff
craig shirley reagan biographer
presidential historian greg
welcome back and doug weed presidential
historian former advisor george h.w
bush that's the white house where i
remember millie
millie had like a staff and they really
took care of her very beautiful dog
this dog looks like from i'm sorry from
the junkyard and i love that dog
but he looks like he's not been well
cared for no not at all thank you for
having us
uh no he looks very dirty and disheveled
and uh
very unlike a presidential dog like uh
millie or victory or
something else in the past and the pres
in the white house
this isn't the right type of dog
for the white house trump didn't have a
dog
trump seemed unable to understand a
thing about human dog
relationships a junkyard dog
which one of the so-called presidential
experts brought onto the panel to
discuss this
says was a disheveled and dirty
dog this is obama's tan suit
redux but extra stupid because it's not
even about
biden it's about biden's dog this
is obama's mustard choices are bougie
again joe biden has the wrong type of
dog
for the white house and the dog doesn't
look right and look at what they are
doing
they have a panel on which craig shirley
a presidential historian says champ
looks very dirty and disheveled
and very unlike a presidential dog do
you really need
an historian to tell you that or maybe
you could get just one of the people who
held one of those 10-foot trump flags
in palm beach florida on president's day
i don't know that you need an expert
if this is the type of opinion that
you're looking for another
manufactured right-wing scandal these
during presidential administrations of
democrats
these completely imaginary right-wing
scandals
are as certain i guess as death and
taxes death taxes and tan suit
type scandals now was this a deliberate
deflection from the ted cruz fiasco that
was going on
i don't know are right-wingers against
rescue dogs now
it has to be a designer dog from a
breeder to meet their standards and to
be suitable for a president as far as
they're concerned
this is more confirmation about how
different
these two sides of american politics are
i'm the first to say
on many issues democrats and republicans
are too similar
there's not enough daylight between them
but we've talked about
real policy differences and when it
comes to substance versus fluff
under barack obama the scandals were tan
suits
mustard types that type of thing under
trump
it was hey what about the emoluments
clause what about asking foreign powers
for help getting re-elected
what about putting the u.s on the road
to authoritarianism those were the
concerns
now joe biden is president and it's joe
and jill biden's love is fabricated
and joe biden has the wrong type of dog
who's dirty
and to be clear there are already
serious critiques of joe biden
but they're not the ones that right-wing
media wants to make
as i've been saying for weeks what is
going on with coveted relief
that's a real question joe biden said
right away checks are going out it's
almost march there's still no deal
that's real
biden said he would stop deportations in
order to figure out
what to do about immigration he did one
executive order a judge blocked it and
he's done nothing else
he could do more executive orders we
talked about that in detail earlier
today
there are criticisms of joe biden
they're not the ones
that fox news oan and newsmax want to
make
and the desperation of the right wing
to make any democrat look bad is
pathetic if you have to insult a dog
you're really hitting rock bottom and
these people are truly
and completely disgusting one of our
sponsors is privacy
a free service that protects your credit
and debit card i use privacy
every time i buy something online i
installed the app on my phone and the
privacy desktop browser extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number
as soon as i give it to the company and
i know i won't be charged in the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium plans
available but privacy's regular service
is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video